hi Chris I know outside I haven't seen
you since I at midnight and I literally
didn't recognize your first but it's
probably been three years since I've
seen you just in casual clothing I know
and I prefer casual I really don't love
wearing suits and everything I do I have
to put on a suit why is it your choice
because that you develop so much of your
stuff are you like yeah I should be
wearing a suit for this yeah it's sort
of like yeah I should probably dress
like an adult like there was a certain
point cuz I just I have a hundreds of
just you know dumb geeky t-shirts and my
manager was like maybe you should start
dressing like you want to work in
television
alright ravenclaw shirt away and put a
[ __ ] tie on why they cancel at
midnight that was that seems like a
silly move by Comedy Central that was
that your decision because it's such an
easy show not easy but a simple show
that was a massive following right well
I mean it this will sound weird but it
was it was sort of mutual but it was
initiate you know in the spring they
knew that they wanted to have a show at
11:30 that was not at midnight because
they III think there's something like
they get a better ad rate for
politically themed shows they can charge
a higher ad rate for it so you know they
really wanted to create that sort of
Magic Hour you know when it was Stewart
and Colbert now with Trevor and and
Jordan so they really wanted to create
that hour of like really strong
political commentary and everything's
skewing so political now and we I was
just like I hate talking about politics
like we don't have the runway to talk
about it on @midnight because it's just
so fast-paced jokes so we can't really
go in too much in depth on anything and
I'm just so tired of talking about it
and so they were like well you know we
could move you back to midnight or you
know I don't know what are you thinking
and I was like you know I think I don't
know what else to do with the show you
know 600 episodes I don't know what else
to do with it plus you say Chris relate
so much stuff you're really the guy to
look at because you you put together
great ideas and you follow them through
I think that's the biggest thing in show
biz is it's not even just coming up with
ideas it's following through but the
business makes it really hard to follow
through on stuff because you'll pit even
if you pitch stuff everything takes at
least 18 months to happen at least you
pitch something even if they am in the
room go we're gonna do this there's like
three or four months of lawyers doing
[ __ ] then maybe the executives shuffle
around and then they come back and they
give you notes and then they and then
before you know it like two years of
past knowing I only [ __ ] remember
what this was anymore yeah so the
business really does not make it easy to
and the fact that anything gets made and
then anything gets made well is mind
blowing to this does never get
frustrating cuz like I feel like I see
projects that are obviously like we want
it's like a Chris Hardwick idea or
something that you did and they're like
well it's this version but whether it's
talking dead or like there's many
different examples I feel it doesn't
bother me because I it's it's sort of
like oh yeah like you know we did
something we did something that works so
of course you know and I don't I think
it's great that there are after shows
and when that midnight came out I mean
we didn't you know like there's a
million shows like at midnight in
England they're just really aren't any
here right so we did at midnight you
know a couple people tried to do panel
shows but they're really they're really
hard to do like it's not if the show
shows a lot of work to make it look
really seamless but you were always
really great on the show Jim thank you
and I appreciate you having me on
believe you're one of two people who
would have me on television I'd love
this part with that show was so
tailor-made for you to it's just like
quick jokes get in get out you know like
say whatever you want and you know no no
censoring really and then they never
[ __ ] with me about jokes there and
likely it was just it was it was a
really fun show to do and you don't get
that many opportunities to kind of like
you said fire quickly and and if it
lands it lands if it doesn't I honestly
then when we did the show was kind of
innovative here in the States but then
after four years it just wasn't anymore
I was like God people have seen it
social media has evolved and changed so
much even since the time we started it
just we just literally didn't know what
else to do with it
was there a relief to it being over in a
sense that now you don't have this daily
responsibility to go yes I love the show
I don't miss the schedule right it just
cuz I work on a bunch of stuff and so it
just it was it was crazy for a while
doing two days a week at one point like
two shows a day on whatever Monday
Wednesday just to try to cut down and
free you up see if some kind of like
yeah exactly initially it was Monday
through Wednesday we do the Thursday
show late Wednesday and then we switched
to Monday Wednesday and and it just got
yeah it just got really crazy and then I
just felt like I can't
I'm not gonna be as good if I'm
about ten other things and you know the
show requires that you be insanely
present the entire time so and you what
you're a great host but it's one of
those things where if you find something
that's newer that you're like a little
more excited about or that you just you
have to focus on it's hard to stay
focused on the thing you've been doing
that you already know one no but I just
I love stand-up so much and I love you
know I loved being able to like you know
be go to the improv and you know like
see Tiffany Haddish and go my god I've
never seen her before and then booked
her on the show and she kills yeah and
and just sort of watching people like
we're on Funches
just like watching people really the
rest of the world discover how oh yeah
yeah what was your relationship like -
with Joan Rivers I don't know if I knew
you had a friendship with her oh yeah
I'm kind of jealous of that she's one of
the comedians who I one of my favorite
people ever the most underrated comic
ever and I never ly got to know her yeah
I when I first started doing the Nerdist
podcast we had her on cuz we did it I
worked at g4 and that was in the e
building so she did her show there so we
got her on and we just totally clash we
just hit it off and the reason Joan was
so remarkable even it you know and again
she did not die of natural causes I
think she'd still be alive doing gigs -
it's still doing gigs and what it really
taught me was that you never get old as
long as you remain inquisitive and
curious
she never like blew off anything that
was new she was so interested in
learning about technology and podcasting
and live-streaming and so she would call
me every once in a while and go Chris
it's Joan listen um I want to do a
YouTube show what's the best way to
promote like she was still pitching
ideas we would have lunch or I'd go to
her house and we talk about stuff and
then you know and I was but I was really
heartbroken when she died cuz she was I
mean that that that work ethic and how
many different eras of comedy she's seen
and what a pioneer she was and she was
fearless
and she doesn't get the credit like
people know she was funny and kind of
like she's in the atmosphere way but I
remember seeing her at the cutting room
probably 12 years ago ten years ago when
the girl I was dating and I watched her
and she repeated one joke at an hour she
had notes on the floor she's older
people forget she was 80 right and it
was and I've said this before it was the
most barbaric set I've ever seen stand
up there and I mean a [ __ ] 911
I know yeah ha and it was as a comic I'm
watching I'm like she's so pure at what
she does and the fact that she's not
considered in the top five or ten
comedians is crazy I would put her up
there especially because you know she
came from a school of comedy that was
you know when she first started
performing a lot you know she was you
were working in the village with like
simon and garfunkel we're doing open
mics and you know they worshiped
everyone worshipped Lenny Bruce and she
was in an era where comedy was really
about making social commentary and so
she just wasn't afraid to talk about
stuff that you know other people would
be afraid to talk about and she was
clean in fact you go on The Tonight Show
in 1969 and talk about being a [ __ ] or
the fact that you're lousy in bed you
know I mean the fact that you can talk
about this stuff and get away with it
nobody I didn't lose Taylor sue her I
think for bashing her so yeah she went
after a really hard I got to see Joan
when I was a kid my parents used to go
to Vegas a lot and I saw I saw Steve
Martin perform I saw I saw Joan open for
Johnny Carson in the 70s and we my
parents went up to her after the show
and she just couldn't have been lovelier
like really sweetly johnny was doing
stand-up in the 70s she was doing
stand-up yeah he'd pop over to Vegas and
he would do a show and it wasn't it was
sort of stand-up but he would do bits
like these sort of long it's kind of new
hard esque bits or it was like oh the
you know the drunken teacher with a
hangover and so there were a lot of like
weird sound effects and it was him
acting out so it was kind of it wasn't
as much joke telling as it was like like
sketchy bits but yeah he used to he used
to pop over and do that was he
entertaining yeah it was great I mean
you know and also at that time he was a
[ __ ] like most famous guy on
television you know like 40 50 million
people a night watch that which is
mind-blowing and what is it - like with
technology and stuff like I was talking
to somebody who was younger about
Richard Pryor and they're like whoo yeah
and I'm like III can't comprehend that
somebody who doesn't know but a lot of
people don't know who Johnny Carson was
sure so what is it about people now that
they don't seem to have long like people
used to have longevity like I was like I
saw Clockwork Orange when I was a
teenager even though it came out when I
was 3 but it seems like now is that the
technology or the fact that there's so
many things available is what it is
there's so much content and also there's
so much niche content like you can get
any
you know it's like recommendation
engines are telling you stuff that you
already you're probably gonna like we
don't really have to we used to have to
seek out entertainment or at least in
the entertainment business - there were
so few entertainment portals that
everyone had to watch the same stuff
it's like there were three channels
there's only a handful of movies opening
and if you didn't want to watch that
stuff then you just didn't get
entertainment so I think that was a lot
of it because I'm sure people don't even
I'm sure there's young people who are
like Sam Kinison who you know Bill Hicks
what there's a lot of people don't know
who they are
you'd be surprised how people don't know
kinnison again I guess he died in was in
91 yeah it was running yeah was 91 dead
for 30 years um and as a host but who is
the guy you look at is no cuz you're a
great host oh thanks man you you're
comfortable you're likable I think
Carson was my favorite but then I
watched Jack Paar clips and my Jack
Bauer was [ __ ] awesome like he was a
comfortable funny dude yeah and that you
know a lot of those guys just really
well Dick Cavett to I mean yes dick was
masterful at you know he never wanted
this he never seemed to steal the
spotlight he was so good at just setting
people up and then just letting him go
keeping the ball in the air and that
people just opened up to him so I
thought he was pretty great too but as
far as comedy yeah Jack Paar Carson or
Steve Allen or you know or even like
yeah like match game you know like match
game or Hollywood silly old Hollywood
Squares like everyone was really loose
and was probably cuz they were really
drunk on the set yo yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think richard dawson would get
pretty pretty sauced up how [ __ ] great
is that I would I love knowing that
richard dawson might have been an
alcoholic you know how happy that makes
me
if that's not true I apologize but I do
it's a great you not shocked to hear
that no no no this isn't breaking news
to me
I don't think Paul Lynde was like yeah
it was [ __ ] him I've gone down these
rabbit holes there's so many great
YouTube rabbit holes where you see like
what was it there was like just seeing
Richard Pryor go on Carson or see
I don't know Carlin or these guys and
just watching them kind of talk as
people crawling together around yeah
they were together on yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that was kind of an interesting
conversation because it seemed like they
were both trying to find the rhythm and
like watching these guys who were
masterful when they were in control of
the room be a little uncomfortable when
they were like just having to talk as
themselves as people and also the fact
that they were restricted like people
say all you got to be there's Richard
Pryor was funny or uncensored George
Carlin was funny or uncensored and to
watch that have to try to navigate it
while sitting on a thing instead of
beyond so you're right neither one of
them was 100% comfortable sitting there
in that chair well it's I think it's
hard like if you're a pure pure pure
stand-up it can be really hard if you're
not in control of the microphone if
you're on someone else's show it's sort
of like oh how do i how do I do this I'm
so used to being the one who's
navigating yeah and how do I cut this
word I got this word I want to say but
how do i how do I say it without saying
[ __ ] or whatever the joke is and like
you feel like you're selling it out by
softening and it's not as funny yeah and
and and as much as and as much as it
seems like they had to edit themselves
more back then I almost kind of think in
some senses television was a little more
liberal but back then then it's like in
terms what you can and can't say I mean
you couldn't there were words you
couldn't say but there was subject
matter that people would dance around
you know like naughty subject matter and
freedom to kind of do stuff like you can
do it like you couldn't do Dick Cavett
show now because people don't have the
attention spans we want quicker we don't
we don't want conversation we want we
want you know flash cards in here go
straight to what's the story what's the
problem like a two-minute long show
intro then the show and then a lot of
talking right yeah I remember watching
Dick Cavett because I was preparing for
these talk these talk shows I was trying
which up here they didn't go anywhere
but I loved Dick Cavett and he had John
and Yoko Ono Yoko Ono we're backstage
waiting so he's doing his monologue and
he's just kind of yapping and he decides
to raffle off his tie and it was a
[ __ ] awful bit and I loved him for it
because he didn't rush he was just like
I'm just raffling off my tie and you
know how he would never hurry
no and I'm right this dog [ __ ] bit with
the two biggest stars in the world
waiting to come on
like that he didn't panic he didn't
ganas just hit the bar let's go and then
rush it it was just casual yeah I was
very very very comfortable it was almost
his show was almost kind of podcast
especially like the Betty Davis episode
is insane because she was just
incredible and you know told all these
crazy crazy stories and he just knew how
to kind of pride people to just get him
to open up well he did have the one
advantage to of now it's not special to
hear a celebrity talk like back then
when Marlon Brando sat down and you're
like oh my god he's gonna talk it's
bright Marlon gonna talk now no one
gives a [ __ ] you celebrities talk
everywhere use on TMZ I can catch him on
there you know they're posting videos so
it's not specialty [ __ ] famous now
everyone everyone's famous because of
social media so it doesn't really mean
anything any back then though if you
heard a celebrity saying something like
oh my god I can't believe me thoughts on
things I like Mike Douglas - he was
[ __ ] he would this let a story
lay there and he would you wouldn't try
to save it I was on that show when I was
a kid because my dad was a professional
bowler and I was a really good bowler
when I was a kid and and so I but you
will appreciate this as a comedy nerd I
bowled against Jimmy Walker on the Mike
Douglas show in like 1980
that's one I did he was a really good
bowler
ya see Ron Mike that's who lost result
was that Todd tiger was wasn't Tiger
Woods Tiger well I think was on that -
yes it was a Mike Douglas his father
bought him I forget who thinks they were
on with was it or no idea very famous
clip of her everything was a different
guy Tiger Woods his father bringing a
llama you see yeah it was it that who it
was and you know someone's bringing it
up now thinks I'm trying to bring it up
Tiger Woods first TV appearance Mike
Douglas Bob Hope Jimmy Stewart what
would you yeah that's something that's a
couple of cool guys to be honest so you
are you bowled against why'd you stop
bowling by the way I don't know it just
it didn't really you know my dad was
like yeah yeah no need to be yeah I mean
if I wanted to be a bowler he would have
been cool with it but it just I wanted
to be an entertainment you know like
bowling was fun but once you get singled
out you probably
I want to be on the profiling yeah the
Pro Bowlers sewer is rough because
there's no there's no real money in it
and even like the top guys
only you know or earn a couple hundred
grand a year which is and it's like only
a few of them do and then the rest of
them is just like just like a regular
job like 30 40 50 grand how do they make
money they are there certain
endorsements they'll do for it was it
was a MP is that the big bowl laughs
yeah here's AMF and Brunswick and
there's a few companies and so they they
might do endorsements but really it's
just about the grind it's kind of funny
cuz my dad like being a stand-up it was
very similar to the life that my dad had
in the Pro Bowlers tour like when he was
still alive if I was performing in some
city I go hey you know I'm in Tucson and
he'd go oh I bowled in 1972 at the
bowl-a-rama
over there on Jackson Street so we I was
I was almost kind of like weirdly
following him his life just as a
stand-up just not as a bowl but getting
laid while he let's be honest comics get
laid more than ballers I oh no I was I'm
a serial monogamist I never I never I
never really went through that phase
like I'm gonna go on the road and hook
up I just never did that even after like
even after you started like once you
started getting all these TVs you got
super super famous never because I can't
Chris Hardwick it needs this creator and
he's this famous guy and I know many
women did find you very attractive well
that's very kind
i I just I'm not a good date er and I
just like being in a relationship like I
went from a seven-year relationship into
a three-year relationship and then the
next person was my wife like you know
three years okay yeah we were we dated
for a year and we got engaged after a
year and then we got married after two
years and now we were married so if you
had just gone through a couple
relationships where they they went long
and they ended how did you know after a
year that this one was different uh you
know I I just did I don't know I you
know when I was young I used to sort of
think that that drama in a relationship
was like passion and I think it had to
do with the fact that you know I'm a
recovering alcoholic and so we just like
drama you know and then when I met Lydia
she was very even-keeled and very sweet
and wonderful and I was like oh wait I
think you know like nah
being in a dramatic situation is
probably way better supposed to be and
she's just the [ __ ] best that's a
great way to put it that you weak people
confuse like drama with passion yeah get
you all riled up or like yeah it's real
high highs real real real low lows you
think you got depth - you got problems
and fears man and and one relationship
isn't like most relationships is why a
lot of alcoholics and a lot of people in
recovery get real fidgety if
everything's just even mm-hmm cuz they
just it's just that spike you know it's
like the adrenaline spike and the
serotonin spike and just all those up
and down up and down up and down which
is you know what we do when we're
drinking or taking drugs or whatever it
is and you realize after a while like oh
my god I'm doing the emotional version
of that addiction thing so how did you
feel because you kind of I would imagine
went through something similar in your
career where like for a while you were
trying to figure out how am I gonna make
this work how many sure and then things
really started working they did but it
just took so many years but but but it
really everything really changed like
ten years ago where I was just like I
wasn't working I had no job prospects I
was broke no I no one was coming to see
me do stand-up and so I was like you
know what do I want to do like what do I
really care and I'd never asked myself
that question before and so I just
started looking at what I was good at
what I like doing and that's the subject
matter of things that I liked I was like
you know as long as that because when
you start out I think you go oh I just
want a lot of something line up whatever
it is money or fame or whatever it is
and then I was like I think I just want
to be happy so I'm just gonna focus on
things that make me happy that I enjoy
and if I can survive doing that that's
ultimately all you can ask for
did you ever struggle or is it difficult
now to like maintain coz this whole
thing I think for you this phase started
with you being a fan of things yes
you're sure is it difficult to maintain
that degree of fandom when number one
you've got all this work to do because
you've got all these gigs and number two
people become such a fan of you being a
fan that you almost I'm like am I still
right am i still authentic because I you
know I mean I don't know I don't know if
I even have the right but proper
perspective on that I just think you
know I it does limit the amount of
thing like I've watched so much stuff
for work right that it limits the amount
when people go have you seen
such-and-such I'm like no not yet no
look I thought you were like yeah I'm a
nerd with like six jobs I'm like I'm
busy I'm doing I do my best and you get
to a place to where you're watching
something and you're like wait am I
still a fan of this or am i watching
this because I my job is to be a fan of
I actually am still good at watching
stuff as and just being a fan of stuff
and not being not being too jaded or too
weird about stuff and you know I mean
I'd stay on talking dead I don't go
after Walking Dead at all in a way where
people are like we've recruited so this
show it's like yeah but if you look at
everything I do I'm not like that with
anything right cuz they cuz you know
it's you you could be negative about
anything or you could be positive about
pretty much anything and I just think
there's enough negativity in the world
amazing when fans of a thing get mad at
you for being a fan of the same thing
and not complaining about it well yeah
they get really mad because you know
we're sort of in this age of they're
sort of in this age of like engineered
narcissism where people are so we're so
spoiled as consumers to get things
exactly how we want when we want you
know deliver the way that we want and
when things don't hundred-percent line
up with the way that we want them we
flip the [ __ ] out and if someone doesn't
agree with that like you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
right no I just have a different opinion
than you yeah well your opinion [ __ ]
okay well it's my opinion [ __ ] how do
you handle the negative people we all
get it we all get the hate and that's
kind of common your publisher I get
people gonna hate your guts they're
gonna love you so how do you do it I try
to ignore most of it and then other
people I'm just I just engage with them
in a nice way and I'm like hey I'm I'm
sorry this is your interpretation of
this thing I'm just a guy doing a thing
not trying to ruin your day and most of
the time people be like I was just had
because social media has become an
extension of our emotional brain like
there's no more filter it's just
whenever you have an emotion you
immediately put it on social media and
it's a snapshot of however you were
feeling in that moment and in five
minutes you may not even feel that way
anymore because people go oh yeah I was
just uh I was just those just upset
that's a great point why have we not
recognized that like we I think we know
it as individuals it's a snapshot of how
you're feeling yeah but
why do we still take [ __ ] on social
media and go that's the gospel that's
how it is because it's in text it's
written down and it's recorded I mean if
you it's sort of like social media is
kind of like when you're driving in your
car and you're just shouting at other
people in traffic but it's shared like
if someone can hear you shouting and
traffic like what a monster be like oh I
don't mean any of that I just but we
haven't we haven't there's so many
people haven't gotten past the point of
I saw that imprint right must be real
and yet just know everybody just has the
ability to yeah I mean it's like people
say things and you take you you act like
everyone who says something is a
reasonable happy person that walks up to
you at a party and says hey your shows
dumb and [ __ ] you and your shirts stupid
be like hey why would you you know it's
just you it's there there's kind of a
weaponized and anima T behind it there's
no accountability anymore people don't
have to answer for anything that they
say so it's just sort of a venting thing
and they don't you know and most people
there's a lot of people who if you call
them out will double down on their
position sure you know and be like oh I
guess you can't take criticism like no I
can take criticism but you called me a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's not just insulting
yeah yeah well you're just a [ __ ]
baby okay well now you're still
insulting me that people do mistake not
like they want to be able to talk to you
like like like a [ __ ] and then if you
respond to that - like you through Cruz
- there's like no if you actually wrote
me a reasonable email my emails on my
Twitter yeah and said look man I don't
like the show because I think you guys
are doing this in this room you would
engage with them and go oh well I
understand that here's why we do this I
could take a look at that
you know never fired back [ __ ] you at
somebody that has just been critical I
actually listen to a lotta and sometimes
they're right people will a lot of times
tell you [ __ ] you don't want to hear
that makes sense they're not always
wrong and I agree with you - like when
when people if people have a criticism
for you know talking dead or something
or whatever and they go hey you know I
really sucks that you do this that I
really do listen I go okay well this is
a this is a fan centric show you're a
fan you're upset you know maybe I should
take a look at this how can I do better
and most of time they go hey I really
appreciate that you they could start
with rage and they go really appreciate
that you listen I go yeah we can just
have conversations yeah but there was
something really interesting that I've
discovered that never occurred to me
because when people attack you usually
think like wouldn't obnoxious [ __ ]
they must think they're [ __ ] awesome
and the sad truth is a lot of people who
go really hard
you are unhappy and when you engage with
them or if your feelings are hurt
I've had people go what the [ __ ] do you
care what my opinion is I'm nobody and
they actually respect you less because
they think so little of themselves and
that you responding to them means that
you you know you must think a lot not
you must not have a high self esteem
because they don't have I stating but
it's also a way out for them when
they're losing argument like a lot of
times if someone it's like a radio show
will smash a bigger radio show and then
the bigger radio show responding goes
[ __ ] you and then they go what do you
care what we say for we're just small
radio show that's almost an excuse for
like hey we just want to talk [ __ ] and
not be responded to yeah that's it like
and but I think it goes a little bit
further because I've had some
interactions on reddit where I think oh
not only do you not want me to really
say anything about your dissection of me
you want me to thank you for like it's
not even a they go oh I guess we don't
have free speech you go yeah you're not
going to jail for your opinion
you're entitled to your opinion but
other people are entitled to their
opinion about your opinion that's now
discourse works as a I mean this is off
topic but as a horror movie geek and
fanatic yes
I was so happy in general and happy for
you when I read about the deal that you
have with bluem House diplomacy yeah
yeah yeah I mean there's nobody making
films like Blum House like every I and I
didn't even really because I don't
necessarily pay attention to you know
production is there anything I just
watch movies but I it was like I don't
know maybe three years ago or something
I started like just taking an inventory
of all the movies that we're coming out
and I like saying all of them yeah and
then I go and find bloom house and like
just give me the list of everything
they're doing and it's just like movie
after movie after movie it's amazing the
the the stuff they're coming out with
especially for the genre it's a really
good group to like they really genuinely
care about hell yeah yeah so it's not
just I mean of course you know they're
in a business of course they want to
make money but it's not it's not it
doesn't feel like just a cash grab all
right they're not doing that like sort
of a tease thing where they're just
throwing some swash slasher made like
the old hammer film
those remember the old hammer studios in
London that would made horror films what
made their movie so good compared to a
lot of other I don't know I mean I just
think it's sort of you don't like them
no I did but with that or even like
Roger Corman like when a film even if
it's not traditionally like classically
great in the you know in the Academy
Awards sense if something is a really
strong point of view I mean that's all
like Ed Wood was that way too it's like
oh it was all point-of-view driven yeah
or you can feel like you can feel the
creator behind it I can feel the person
who wrote or directed somebody's hands
are on this yeah exactly exactly it's
almost like their style is a character
yeah and you buy into that character and
it's great like somebody wanted to make
this movie not just for the business
reasons but they actually wanted this
movie to exist right but I'm just going
back a minute I'm thinking you guys and
you especially Jim because because your
stand up voice is so you go so hard
after stuff I would tend to bet that
people think that they have to go hard
after you because that's how you
communicate you would guess right I
don't know what their motives are but
boy when they go or they think it they
think they're part of the humor if
they're like hey what's up you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you're like hey come on man
that's a staged thing you know if they
just said that if they just said come on
you [ __ ] [ __ ] be like I'll look it
up mildly really funny too you can't
deny that some of them are [ __ ]
really really fun I don't think yeah I
think you know I think people don't
quite understand that all can mean part
of what makes a comedian a comedian is
that we are you know we sort of absorbed
the world we're very sensitive to the
world but that means we're also very
sensitive people and a lot of us are
very insecure and a lot of us have the
issues and you know so when people just
start poking of course you know but on
it but watching the way the watching the
way people like more famous people
interact online has taught me like oh
yeah it doesn't always look great when
you get petty you know it's like you you
really do that you really a way to
address it was a way to address it yeah
yeah and you certainly don't to address
the way Kevin Spacey did that was not a
good way to come back with a allegation
let's just come out no no no do you have
to put out that statement yeah and
that's the last thing he said on Twitter
your call yeah yeah yeah people are not
too
keen on that like you're just using that
as an excuse and now you're making this
whole community look bad because that's
your excuse
you know have you ever have you ever
gotten to a place where like because I'm
sure people talk to you about like well
now you have this voice now you have
this influence you should be talking
about politics sure you should be
talking to people people people want you
people have an idea of what they think
you shouldn't shouldn't be talking about
but I sort of feel like you really need
to talk about you're passionate about
and and if you if I were really
passionate about politics I would talk
about it but the problem is it's
basically mostly an echo chamber right
people who already agree with you're
gonna go yes and people don't agree with
you're gonna go [ __ ] you and you're not
gonna change anyone's mind and I also I
don't like things that divide people and
the second I start you know the second I
get political it just divides be
especially the Jews they always get that
it just divides people and that makes me
sad like it doesn't cuz everyone goes
into defensive mode and it's just all
shouting my friend you know baratunde a
Thurston no it's great he used to work
at the onions brilliant guy comedian
yeah he's comedy guy yeah no I don't
think he actually does stand-up but he's
a comedy guy and but he's just a
brilliant thinker and and he was saying
that um you know he was saying social
media has become so performative that
people feel like they need to like
perform their opinions in a way that's
so overly dramatic rather than just
having conversations and so I just I
don't like things that divide people I
like I want comedy to be for me I want
it to be fun I want it to bring people
together no matter what you know and and
so you know when people say you
shouldn't I like yeah but I wouldn't be
very good at it like it wouldn't be good
if you're not natural natural for me it
would feel inauthentic right you are and
you married to you married into the
Hurst family which is a great job I'm
sure you fell in love and I'm sure
that's why if there is there any odd
feelings marrying into such a legendary
or fab I mean I know it's something a
dumb question but I've never I've never
been involved with it no no it's like
you would you honestly wouldn't really
know if you didn't know I mean they're
super nice normal sweet people I haven't
encountered anything that's like you
know like it's everyone's they're just
all really cool where was your wedding
we did it in
at this hotel called the the Langham
Huntington was a really nice really nice
it was great it was really great Johnny
won we went to Japan I've never been now
here it's really nice it's great it's
beautiful Japan's beautiful what are you
two weeks we did two weeks we were in
Tokyo for a couple days and then you can
take the bullet train and be pretty much
anywhere in like an hour and a half and
we just went all around the southern
part of the island and it was just a
it's such an amazing place is it
expensive I heard I want to go by the
price it is but it's worth it you know
like in New York - yeah that's true but
I think it is more I think it is pricier
than Manhattan I believe it is yeah but
it's but it's great it's worth it's
worth it if you're gonna invest in
anything having an experience but you
really have to go out and see you know
just see the village